thanks to mac weldon for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me
look fly well because this is clearly
the darkest timeline
many have asked and now i must answer
the question what if the president
refuses to leave the white house
you'll never take me alive coppers get
[Music]
him
legal eagles it's time to think like a
lawyer and the secret service
as i discussed in a recent video joe
biden is now the clear winner
of the 2020 election and donald trump's
lawsuits are not going to be enough to
change that result
after it looked obvious that president
trump could not get enough votes to be
re-elected the media started asking
whether president trump would make a
concession speech
president trump did not win enough votes
to win the election but he has so far
refused to concede his loss
and although no president has ever
refused to leave office other elected
officials in the u.s
have thrown tantrums after losing an
election in 1874 texas governor edmund
davis locked himself in the basement of
the state capitol building after losing
to richard koch
like trump davis claimed that there had
been voter fraud and the state supreme
court with three judges appointed by
davis ruled in his favor
but coke was still inaugurated koch then
arrived at the state capitol with the
sheriff's posse
but davis appealed to fellow republican
president ulysses s grant for federal
troops
but grant refused davis left three days
later
in 1946 there was a standoff in georgia
known as the three governors crisis
after the governor elect died before
taking office the outgoing governor
thought he had a right to stay the son
of the governor-elect thought he should
inherit the office
and the lieutenant governor-elect
believed that he was now governor
bizarrely the state assembly voted for
the son to inherit the office
the two other men were still in the
building but that crisis ended when the
governor-elect's son
changed the locks but if that happens
this year i'll finally get to
collaborate with the lock-picking lawyer
now president trump hasn't locked
himself in the bathroom yet but he is
refusing to concede that he lost
normally the loser would have given a
public concession speech by now that's
what jimmy carter did when ronald reagan
defeated him in 1980
and what george h.w bush did in 1992
when he lost his re-election bid to bill
clinton
but what is a concession speech well
it's a public acknowledgement by the
loser of the presidential race that he
or she has lost the election
this is not a legal requirement but it
is an important norm that ensures the
peaceful transfer of power
especially since the incumbent commands
you know the whole military until the
next president takes office
the concession speech generally allows
the rest of the steps required to
confirm the election results to move
forward
after the loser concedes lots of things
happen behind the scenes
this triggers the release of millions of
federal dollars to the transition team
along with access to office space and
necessary equipment like computers and
money
under the 2015 presidential transitions
improvement act
which amended the 1963 presidential
transition act
the president must establish a white
house coordinating committee and council
of agency transition directors
six months prior to the election
typically the administrator of the
general services administration or gsa
signs a letter when the winner of the
race is quote apparent
this acts as the federal government's
formal declaration that the presidential
race is over and a winner has
emerged although every agency including
the gsa has detailed transition plans as
required by law
the washington post has reported that
the plans won't move forward until a
winner is declared by the gsa
this could mean a number of different
things that the transition won't happen
until trump gives up or that everyone is
waiting for the supreme court to
declare a winner but that's kind of not
how this happens
in his guidance in april on how agencies
should be preparing the office of
management and budget
noted that the committee would meet on
may 27th however
the gsa refused to publish the full
minutes of this meeting
we now know that emily murphy the
president trump appointed administrator
of the general services administration
is refusing to sign a letter that
immediately allows the transfer of power
from one administration to the next when
the washington post asked her why her
spokesperson said quote
an ascertainment has not yet been made
and its administrator will continue to
abide
by and fulfill all requirements under
the law
what these two facts the omb censoring
the transition meeting notes and murphy
refusing to acknowledge the reality of
president trump's loss
what do those tell us at a minimum the
trump team has no intention of
cooperating with a peaceful transition
of power
and both president trump and members of
his cabinet have hinted that they are
not going to comply with a peaceful
transition
uh with in particular mike pompeo the
secretary of state saying that
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
but the stakes of a delayed transition
are actually higher than one might think
the bipartisan 911 commission found that
the delayed transition in 2000 between
the clinton and bush administrations
actually made the 911 attacks more
likely because it hampered the incoming
w bush administration from focusing on
the looming al-qaeda threat from day one
the delayed transition in 2020 might
undermine efforts to distribute a
covet-19 vaccine
as the u.s hits an all-time high for
positive coronavirus tests
the trump cobit task force has stopped
meeting and its chair mike pence is
trying to go on vacation but on top of
screwing up the transition there's all
kinds of stuff that a nefarious
squatting president
could do on the way out this probably
deserves its own video but
those steps could include firing not
only political appointees who the
president doesn't like but also career
staff to just
gum up the works we've seen that already
by president trump firing defense
secretary mike esper and the potential
firings of fbi director chris wray
and cia director gina haspel the
president has also named michael ellis
as
nsa general counsel in these waning
months
and you'll remember that name if you've
watched my video on how the white house
conducted a political motivated review
of john bolton's book
ellis was the political operative who
took a hatchet to it and prevented it
from being published
these could be chaos moves or attempts
to install true believers to take
affirmative action benefiting president
trump
the president could pardon everyone in
his orbit including his family his
friends his co-conspirators and
maybe even himself and that's not even
with respect to
underlying investigations themselves as
national security analyst asha irangapa
points out the trump doj could induce
the office of legal counsel to adopt all
kinds of formal positions to
justify the president's prior acts and
to the extent there are actually open
investigations into president trump
personally and his family
the department of justice could paper
over these files adding memos that
justify closing of the cases or saying
that the cases were never brought in
good faith in the first place
and calling in to doubt the evidence
that's in those investigatory files
and then of course there are the files
themselves while destroying records that
have administrative historical
informational or evidentiary value under
the presidential records act is usually
illegal
it's probably a good idea to keep an eye
out for grey smoke coming out of the
white house chimneys in the coming days
but all of that is during the
transitional period what if donald trump
remains in denial about the election
and continues barking orders at the
military and holds on to the football
well joe biden is scheduled to be sworn
in as president at noon on january 20th
2021 so as of that date what happens if
president trump is still throwing a
tantrum and won't leave what if he is a
trespasser on the white house
grounds well let's start with the secret
service
the president loses all constitutional
authority when his term ends on january
20
2021 at this time he no longer commands
the armed forces or the secret service
both of those entities will be commanded
by joe biden
when president biden arrives at the
white house after his inauguration he'll
be accompanied by
moving vans and the u.s secret service
the secret service is a law enforcement
agency within the department of homeland
security
the secret service has two roles they
investigate counterfeiting and other
federal crimes
and they protect national leaders and
their families as well as foreign
dignitaries
but what happens if a president the
secret service is sworn to protect
decides that he's still president and
won't leave the white house grounds
under the former president's act the
secret service provides lifetime
protection to former presidents and
their families
president trump will be assigned a
secret service protection unit that
takes over after he is no longer
president but that doesn't mean that
president trump has legal authority over
his post-presidential
team the secret service is led by a
director the current director is james
murray
the director is appointed by and serves
at the pleasure of the president and is
not subject to senate confirmation
when biden becomes president murray
reports to biden and not trump if it
came down to a battle between
president biden's protective team versus
trump's protective team
well it won't because president biden
and director murray
would order former president trump's
security detail to stand down
but could some members of the secret
service decide to disobey
biden's orders and fight for trump i
mean theoretically but they'd be
committing a felony
section 3056d of title 18 prohibits
knowingly and willfully obstructing
resisting
or interfering with a federal law
enforcement agent who is engaged in
protective functions
and if former president trump's security
detail was prosecuted under 18 usc
3056 it's not even necessary to show
that trump's guys used force against
federal law enforcement agents
even blocking the entry to the white
house grounds or the white house doors
is considered obstruction or resistance
and of course the law does authorize
secret service agents to arrest anyone
engaging in activity which could nullify
or reduce the effectiveness of security
precautions
taken by the secret service that means
if former president trump's secret
service team locks the doors to the oval
office or bathroom
they could be arrested and the
government doesn't even need to prove
that this interference was forcible or
aggressive it's also a felony under 18
usc 111 to forcibly assault resist
oppose
impede intimidate or interfere with
federal law enforcement officers
including secret service agents in the
performance of their duties
people who work for secret service are
well versed in these laws and many of
them have served for decades
it's highly unlikely that large numbers
of them would turn the white house into
the alamo
and there are also other secret service
support units that could be called on to
help oust a squatting former president
trump
the secret services uniform division
protects facilities and venues secured
for us secret service protectees
including the white house complex and
the vice president's residence at the
naval observatory
these are probably the people who would
be called on to repel any threats to the
white house or the vice president's
residence
so if president trump asked the proud
boys to no longer stand by but to
actually engage
these are probably the people that would
act immediately
and the secret service also has some
specialized units which could be called
upon to remove trump and his allies the
emergency response team provides a
coordinated tactical response for the
white house and other protected
facilities
the counter-sniper team uses observation
sighting equipment and high performance
weapons to
provide a secure environment for
protectees and if a
trump militia were on the scene those
special units would coordinate
a response and then there's also the
motorcade support unit providing
motorcycle tactical support for
official movements of motorcades so
president biden would be safely escorted
to the white house premises
even if an army of lifted ford f-250
trucks with giant oversized flags
showed up to block president biden's
advance and frankly i wouldn't mess
around with the secret service they have
plenty of firepower to back it up
agents and officers use the fn p90
submachine gun the nine millimeter hnk
mp5 a 12 gauge remington shotgun and a
556 sr16 qcb rifle
they also have plenty of non-lethal
options as well like a 16
inch expandable baton and also pepper
spray
now to be clear none of this is going to
happen
the worst case scenario is that a
president biden would simply kindly ask
former president trump to leave
and i'm sure that president trump will
have plenty to do
and plenty of places to go when his term
expires but
if push came to shove the secret service
would be capable of perp walking
former president trump out and dumping
him onto pennsylvania avenue
if not straight into federal prison but
there is
one last wrinkle because the secret
service are not the only guys with guns
in the white house
what about the military well there's
been lots of speculation about whether
donald trump could use the military to
keep himself in power
this isn't likely the military follows a
chain of command and when joe biden is
sworn in
he will be the commander in chief and
president trump loses all authority
if president trump makes any kind of
order after noon on january 20th 2021
the military will not follow those
orders and it's also worth noting that
america has laws mandating political
neutrality by members of the military
the military is not supposed to dabble
in domestic affairs
the uniform code of military justice or
ucmj is the code of conduct applicable
to members of the armed forces and
certain other individuals
closely associated with the armed forces
the ucmj sets forth procedures for
trials by court's marshal
and other disciplinary actions to
enforce these laws now it's important to
note
that the ucmj does not apply to the
president but
article 88 of the ucmj does make it a
crime for any officer
in the armed forces to quote use
contemptuous words against officials of
any branch of the us government
or any state government the officer
cannot make any derogatory
statements against the u.s president and
if a person does
he or she could be court-martialed yes
this is an impingement on the officers
first amendment rights but it's
something that they knowingly give up
when they join the military
article 88 is one of the many reasons
you don't see active duty military
officers critiquing donald trump
they are sworn to uphold political
neutrality however what if they're
called upon by a president to do
something that's arguably illegal or
given orders by
an ex-president well the military is not
supposed to
obey illegal unconstitutional orders
obviously we hope we don't ever get to a
point where
military officers have to decide whether
orders are illegal
or not it's up to military leadership to
ensure that
all presidential orders are lawful but
if joe biden is president then he
is the commander-in-chief if president
trump tries to order the military to do
anything then that
is an illegal order and when it comes to
presidents gone wild we have one
close historical example to go by when
nixon's time was running out back in
1974 many feared that he
would lean on his good friend who just
happened to be the commandant of the
marine corps
now the story is that secretary of
defense james slushinger
was so worried about nixon issuing
illegal orders that he told the joint
chiefs of staff
not to implement any direct orders from
president nixon
that was not relayed through slushinger
now we don't know if this story is
historically accurate historians
disagree about what actually happened
but it does show that military
leadership have given lots of thought to
what might happen if a president started
a meltdown and in fact mark milley the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
said that the military would not be
involved in moderating or intervening
any disputes
we do not take an oath to an individual
no we do not take an oath to a country a
tribe
or religion we take an oath
to the constitution in his view it's
congress's job to figure out
what's happening and prevent it not the
militaries milli is correct the
constitution is silent on this exact
scenario however he's probably already
thought about what would happen
if president trump wanted to remain in
power in august
two retired army officers wrote an open
letter to millie stating that if
trump is holed up in the white house
with armed supporters inside
the military must defend the rightful
president stating quote
in the constitutional crisis described
above your duty is to give
unambiguous orders directing u.s
military forces to support
the constitutional transfer of power
should you remain silent you will be
complicit in a coup d'etat
you were rightly criticized for your
prior active complicity in the
president's use of force against
peaceful protesters in lafayette square
your passive complicity in an extra
legal seizure of political power
would be far worse but whether it's the
military or the secret service
on january 20th donald trump doesn't
need to go home but he can't stay here
and as joe biden put it the united
states government is perfectly capable
of escorting trespassers
out of the white house but if president
trump does stay past noon on january
20th
he'll be trading his very poorly
tailored suits and ties
for a matching orange jumpsuit in fact
speaking of ditching the suit
now that the election is over i'm
getting out of here in one of mack
weldon's super comfortable polos
oh wait i can't leave because of covid
all right well i guess i'll just stay
inside wearing one of their warm v-neck
sweaters and slim cut chinos instead
because if i'm not in court or on a zoom
call with a judge i'm often wearing mac
weldon i've tried their polos their
t-shirts their shorts and of course
their world famous boxer briefs
and if you're watching this channel
you're an adult and you probably deserve
to have
nice boxer briefs and i can tell you it
makes a world of difference i've ordered
mac weldon many times with my own money
because it looks great
it's incredibly comfortable and it's
great for whether you're just lounging
around or
engaging in sporting activity and gate
that's such a lovely thing to say i mean
playing sports
i usually order multiple sizes so i can
try them on and return the ones that
don't fit and keep the ones that fit
perfectly
now if you would like to try mac welding
you can get 20 off your first order by
just going to macweldon.com
legaleagle or you can use the promo code
legaleagle at checkout
and mac weldon's loyalty program will
get you 20 off free shipping and access
to new products it's automatic when you
sign up in order
at macweldon.com legaleagle you can go
to that url or just click the link in
the description or use the promo code
legal eagle at checkout
clicking on that link in the description
really helps out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis about
the ridiculous scenario of what would
happen if president trump is a squatter
in the white house
if not leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other
reactions and news pieces about all the
crazy stuff that's happening in america
because
it's all legal and crazy so click on
this playlist
and i'll see you in court